eine neue studie bringt jetzt den beweis
für die theorie die der ausnahme
physiker stephen hawking bereits vor 50
jahren formuliert hatte demnach ist es
unmöglich dass die oberfläche eines
schwarzen loches mit der zeit kleiner
wird doch wie genau passt das mit seiner
diese zusammen dass schwarze löcher mit
der zeit verdampfen
die neue studie eines internationalen
forschungsteams bereitet der physik
kopfschmerzen klicks umsatz im future
bis dreimal pro woche spannendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen
die oberfläche eines schwarzen lochs
wird niemals kleiner nicht beim
verschmelzung oder streuung schwarzer
löcher und auch nicht wenn teilchen
hineinfallen
diese theorie hatte der weltberühmte
physiker stephen hawking bereits vor 50
jahren aufgestellt besonders spannend
für die physik ist das weil diese idee
ganz hervorragend mit dem zweiten gesetz
der thermodynamik zusammenpasst demnach
nimmt die entropie in einem
geschlossenen system immer weiter zu
vereinfacht gesagt kann man sich unter
entropie das maß für unordnung
vorstellen oder anhand einer vase
erklärt dass die vase irgendwann kaputt
geht ist wahrscheinlich dass sie sich
aus ihrem scherben von selbst wieder zu
einer neuen phase zusammensetzten das
ist extrem unwahrscheinlich und kurz die
entropie nimmt zu allerdings kommt der
begriff ursprünglich aus der wärme lehre
und wärme spielt für entropie eine
entscheidende rolle
zusammengefasst ist also die verlaufs
richtung eines wärme prozesses gemeint
der in einem geschlossenen system immer
weiter zunehmen muss und hier auch noch
einmal vereinfacht die teilchen geraten
immer mehr durcheinander
sie bewegen sich immer mehr und das
bedeutet werden und da die entropie
eines schwarzen loches direkt mit seiner
oberfläche zusammenhängt müssten beide
größen immer nur zu aber niemals
abnehmen können so dachte hawking vor
vielen jahren und jetzt ist es endlich
mit hilfe eines experiments gelungen
oder einer studie der untersuchung von
daten dass auch zu bestätigen
dazu sagt einer der beteiligten us
astrophysiker maximiliano easy die
oberfläche eines schwarzen lochs kann
nicht verkleinert werden was dem zweiten
hauptsatz der thermodynamik entspricht
das hat auch eine massen erhaltung da
man seine masse nicht reduzieren kann
eine analogie zur energie erhaltung
anfangs dachten die leute wow das ist
eine coole parallele aber wir erkannten
bald dass dies grundlegend zwar schwarze
löcher haben eine entropie die
proportional zu ihrer fläche ist das ist
nicht nur ein lustiger zufall sondern
eine tiefgreifende tatsache über die
welt die sie offenbaren das
internationale forschungsteam hat sich
für die aktuelle studie bereits
bestehende datensätze noch einmal
genauer angeschaut so konnten verzerrung
im raum zeit gefüge gemessen werden die
vor 1,3 milliarden jahren entstanden
sind damals hatten sich zwei schwarze
löcher mit hoher geschwindigkeit
angenähert und waren dann verschmolzen
analysiert wurden nicht nur die masse
und der spin der beiden ausgangs objekte
sondern auch von dem schwarzen loch das
durch die kollision entstanden war
so konnten die fachleute auf die
oberflächen größe der löcher vor der
kollision schließen das ergebnis ist
wirklich überraschend denn zum einen
bestätigt es dass flächen gesetz von
stephen hawking von vor 50 jahren auf
der anderen seite wirft die neue studie
viele neue fragen auf und offenbart die
größte herausforderung der modernen
physik
alle infos zu diesen neuen spektakulären
erkenntnissen gibt es in diesem video
schwarze löcher sind wohl der grund
warum stephen hawking auch weit über
seinen forschungsbereich bekannt wurde
sein antrieb ich möchte das universum
ganz und gar verstehen ich möchte wissen
warum es so ist wie es ist und warum es
überhaupt existiert das krasse daran 7
hawking beschäftigte sich schon mit
schwarzen löchern als es nicht einmal
beobachtungsdaten dazu gab der physiker
dachte quasi nur mit hilfe seines
eigenen gehirns papier und bleistift
darauf herum und kam so zu der
erkenntnis dass schwarze löcher
keineswegs eine einbahnstraße sind
sondern laut den naturgesetzen
verdampfen müssen eine
quantenphysikalische erscheinung macht
das möglich im vakuum entstehen immer
wieder spontan teilchen paare also da
sind vorher keine teilchen gewesen und
dann entstehen sie in der realen physik
spielen sie eigentlich keine rolle weil
sie sich sofort wieder auslöschen am
ereignishorizont eines schwarzen loches
kann ein solches teilchen paar aber
getrennt werden und somit beide teilchen
real werden eines davon stürzten in das
schwarze loch das andere entkommt der
gravitation und
für hawking strahlung auf diese weise
würde das schwarze loch laut hawking
langsam verdampfen wo geht also die
information hin wenn ein schwarzes loch
verdampft und mit ihm alle objekte die
es eingesaugt hat geht es nach einsteins
relativitätstheorie müsste materie bei
überschreiten des ereignishorizont eines
schwarzen loches verschwinden und zwar
gemeinsam mit der von der materie
transportierten informationen die dann
für immer verloren wären die
quantenmechanik dagegen sieht das anders
demnach kann eine information nicht
vernichtet werden dazu schreibt hawking
im jahr 2013
die information geht nicht verloren sie
wird nur nicht in brauchbarer weise
zurückerstattet es ist so als würden sie
eine enzyklopädie verbrennen streng
genommen geht die in ihr enthaltenen
informationen nicht verloren wenn sie
allen rauch und asche sorgfältig
aufheben aber sie lässt sich sehr schwer
lesen
kurz vor seinem tod vor drei jahren war
eine weitere arbeit von hawking zum
sogenannten informations paradoxen
herausgekommen hier gab es dann sogar
einen lösungsansatz der erklären könnte
wie zumindest ein teil der informationen
eben nicht verloren geht sondern
erhalten bleibt im mittelpunkt dieser
überlegung steht die entropie womit
fachleute den grad der unordnung
beschreiben wenn also ein objekt in
einem schwarzen loch verschwindet steigt
sowohl seine temperatur als auch mit ihm
haben wir ja am anfang gesagt die
entropie das ist ja gleich bedeutend
diese könnte gegebenenfalls mit photonen
also lichtzeichen erfasst werden die den
ereignishorizont des schwarzen lochs
umkreisen
hier kann sich das licht der gravitation
nicht entziehen leider ist damit das
informations paradoxon noch nicht gelöst
denn immer noch nicht ist klar ob die
entropie alles widerspiegelt was in
einem schwarzen noch landet auch stephen
hawkings erkenntnisse zur sogenannten
hawking strahlung sind brillant rocken
nämlich erkannte dass die oft als
staubsauger bezeichneten schwarzen
löcher nicht nur materie verschlucken
bis dahin nahmen die fachwelt an das
schwarzen löchern nichts einfach gar
nicht entkommen kann doch der physiker
wollte herausgefunden haben dass die
mysteriösen objekte strahlung aussenden
und letztendlich langsam verdampfen
bis sie dann irgendwann verschwunden
sind heißt also schwarze löcher halten
nicht bis in alle ewigkeit und das waren
tatsächlich nicht nur überraschende
sondern sogar revolutionäre erkenntnisse
diese strahlung wurde dann einige zeit
später als hawking strahlung bekannt
der physiker ging sogar davon aus dass
es irgendwann einmal ein zeitalter geben
wird in dem im weltall keine schwarzen
löcher mehr existieren was jedenfalls
besonders faszinierend an seinen
überlegungen zur hawking strahlung ist
dass sie durch die anwendung der
quantenmechanik es möglich wird schwarze
löcher dagegen entstehen durch die
überlegung der allgemeinen
relativitätstheorie der größte traum der
physik ist es diese beiden theorien
zusammenzubringen eine große
herausforderung in diesem zusammenhang
experimentell konnte die hawking
strahlung bisher noch nicht endgültig
nachgewiesen werden dies gestaltet sich
als schwierig weil sich schwarze löcher
zum einen in astronomischen distanzen
befinden und dem hawking strahlung wohl
eine sehr geringe intensität hat zudem
könnten andere strahlungs effekte in der
umgebung des lochs diesen effekt
überstrahlen so ist der nachweis der
hawking strahlung bei echten schwarzen
löchern in ihrer natürlichen umgebung
dem kosmos möglicherweise sogar
unmöglich doch die hoffnung vieler
fachleute mit hilfe moderner
teilchenbeschleuniger könnte es gelingen
schwarze löcher künstlich im labor
herzustellen
das us team das jetzt die theorie von
stephen hawking von vor 50 jahren
experimentell bestätigen konnte hatte
die daten der ersten jemals gemessenen
gravitationswellen genauer ins visier
genommen die rede ist von einem echten
meilenstein der physik aus dem jahr 2015
damals gelang es nämlich erstmals die
existenz von gravitationswellen zu
belegen diese verzerrung der raumzeit
hatte albert einstein bereits vor 100
jahren vorausgesagt der nachweis der
gravitationswellen im jahr 2015 gelang
mit hilfe der advanced ligo detektoren
in den usa wir haben ja darüber schon
oft bei klicks umsatz in future
berichtet
nun hatten die forschenden die daten der
gravitationswellen in zwei abschnitte
aufgeteilt zum einen vor
und zum anderen nach der verschmelzung
so berechneten sie dann jeweils die
oberflächen der schwarzen löcher diese
analyse ergab dass die oberfläche des
neu entstandenen lochs größer war als
die der beiden ursprünglich schwarzen
löcher zusammen nach angaben des
forschungsteams bestätigt diese
entdeckung die theorie von stephen
hawking mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von
rund 95 prozent dazu schreiben die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
wir konnten das erstmals beziffert
demnach wird die oberfläche eines
schwarzen loch durch den sogenannten
ereignishorizont begrenzt jenseits
sie kann nichts wirklich gar nichts der
starken anziehungskraft des schwarzen
lochs entkommen nicht mehr licht auch
andere fachleute weltweit bestätigen
dass die neue studie sehr explizit
hawkings theorie belegt fest steht dass
diese theorie aber einer anderen theorie
von hawking widerspricht eine äußerst
spannende sache denn das flächen gesetz
passt nicht mit der idee zusammen dass
schwarze löcher über einen langen
zeitraum hinweg verdampfen könnten diese
folgt den prinzipien der quantenmechanik
ist aber nicht mit der
relativitätstheorie über einzubringen
und wieder wird der modernen physik das
größte rätsel ihres bereichs vor augen
geführt die widersprüche zwischen diesen
beiden fundamentalen theorie dazu sagt
der astrophysiker maximiliano easy ich
bin besessen von diesen objekten weil
sie so paradox sind sie sind extrem
mysteriös und verwirrend aber
gleichzeitig wissen wir dass sie die
einfachsten objekte sind die es gibt und
wie viele es davon gibt das wissen wir
auch nicht denn wenn es tatsächlich mehr
sind als bisher angenommen
dann könnten sie die dunkle materie
bilden und eines davon wäre ganz in
unserer nähe das meint jedenfalls
günther hasinger wissenschaftlicher
direktor der europäischen
raumfahrtagentur esa schwarzes loch in
unserem sonnensystem schwarze löcher
erklären die dunkle materie anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
das geht mit dem abo button unter jedem
video kostet nichts und macht schlau
bis dann bleibt dran